Hallo, mein Name ist Olivia Lan, ich bin Forscherin und Lehrende bei IBM Quantum. Dieses Video markiert den Start einer
brandneuen Reihe auf dem kkit-YouTube-Kanal und unserer Lernplattform namens Quantum Computing in
practice – kurz gesagt: In dieser Reihe zeige ich dir, wie du einen Quantencomputer, der bereits heute existiert, auf sein
volles Potenzial nutzen kannst. Es gibt bereits Milliarden von Videos im Internet über Quantencomputer und ihr zukünftiges Potenzial oder über theoretische Konzepte
hinter der Quantenberechnung, die ebenfalls wichtig sind – sieh dir zum Beispiel „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation"
an, moderiert von John Watrous. Aber in diesem Kurs setzen wir voraus, dass die Lernenden vielleicht schon etwas mehr wissen
als in der Vergangenheit, und wir werden technisch gesehen sehr weit gehen. Das liegt daran, dass wir im vergangenen Jahr – und zum
Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme ist es 2024 – einen Wandel, einen Phasenübergang sozusagen, in eine neue Ära der
Berechnung erlebt haben. Quantencomputer nähern sich endlich dem Punkt, an dem sie nützlich sein können. Auch wenn das Experimentieren mit
kleinen circuits und Quantencomputern nötig war, um unsere Community darin zu schulen, diese Maschinen zu nutzen, führte damals niemand Experimente durch,
die nicht auch auf normalen klassischen Computern hätten durchgeführt werden können. Aber seit heute haben wir eine Ära der
Quantum Utility eingeläutet – und was ist Utility, fragst du dich? Sie unterscheidet sich von Quantum Advantage, der sich so verstehen lässt als
der Punkt, an dem Quantencomputer klassische Computer bei einer sinnvollen Aufgabe übertreffen. Utility hingegen bedeutet,
dass sie anfangen können, miteinander zu konkurrieren – und das ist der nächste natürliche Schritt in der technologischen
Evolution. IBM hat ein Paper veröffentlicht, das letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal zeigte, dass ein Quantencomputer genutzt werden konnte, um
ein physikalisches Modell zu simulieren und mit modernsten klassischen Simulationstechniken mitzuhalten. Er hat sogar den
Brute-Force-Versuchen übertroffen und gibt Forschern einen neuen Weg, den sie für ihre Forschung nutzen können. Warum passiert das alles
jetzt? In den letzten Monaten hat IBM Quantenprozessoren mit über 100 qubits allgemein verfügbar gemacht. Wenn du
bereits Nutzer bist, hast du vielleicht bemerkt, dass wir viele unserer kleineren Prozessoren abgeschaltet haben, um Platz für diese größeren Chips zu schaffen. Wir hielten es wirklich für
wichtig, das zu tun, weil einige qubit-Zahlen klassisch noch problemlos simuliert werden können. Es gibt also
keinen echten Vorteil, der durch die Nutzung dieser Chips erzielt werden kann. Bei 100 qubits ist das jedoch nicht mehr der Fall – sie können
klassisch nicht mehr simuliert werden. Es ist außerdem wichtig zu beachten, dass es sogenannte Simulatoren gibt,
die im Wesentlichen Computerprogramme sind und bestimmte Verhaltensweisen von Quantensystemen nachahmen können, einschließlich Rauschen. Bitte
übersieht aber nicht, was ich gesagt habe: nachahmen. Simulatoren sind keine Quantencomputer. Sie können nicht die Ergebnisse liefern, die
Quantencomputer in diesem Maßstab liefern können. Aber sie sind dennoch ein wichtiger Teil unseres Test-Workflows. Das war also eine sehr
ausführliche Antwort auf die Frage oben auf dieser Folie: Was ist praktisches Quantum Computing? In diesem Kurs werde ich dir realistische
potenzielle Anwendungsfälle für Quantum und die besten Praktiken für den Betrieb und das Experimentieren auf diesen größeren
Prozessoren von heute näherbringen. Für wen ist dieser Kurs also gedacht? Fangen wir mit einer Einordnung
an. Dieser Kurs richtet sich an alle, die neue Anwendungen für Quantencomputer entwickeln möchten, wissen wollen,
wie sie ihre aktuelle Arbeit skalieren können, oder lernen möchten, wie sie Quantum in ihre bestehenden Workflows integrieren können. Ich habe bereits
erwähnt, dass dieser Kurs sehr praxisorientiert sein wird und wir theoretische Aspekte kaum besprechen werden.
Wir erwarten, dass du mit einem grundlegenden Verständnis davon kommst, was Quantenberechnung ist. Wenn du noch nicht ganz so weit bist, macht das nichts – schau einfach
die ersten paar Folgen von John Watrous' Kurs und du bist bereit. Wir möchten auch sicherstellen, dass alle Zuschauenden wissen,
dass dies kein Kurs nur für Physiker oder Informatiker ist. Diese beiden Fächer haben
das Quantum Computing im letzten Jahrzehnt ziemlich dominiert. Wir möchten sicherstellen, dass andere, die mit großen Datenmengen oder
Simulationen arbeiten – wie Ingenieure, Chemiker und Materialwissenschaftler – wissen, dass dieser Kurs auch für sie ist. Zusammenfassend ist dieser
Kurs an ein breites Publikum gerichtet, und wir hoffen, dass du bis zum Ende dabei bleibst. Nach Abschluss dieses Kurses wirst du
verstehen, wie du einen Job im Utility-Maßstab über die Qiskit Runtime erstellen und ausführen kannst, einschließlich des gesamten Workflows.
Du wirst die wichtigsten Arten der Fehlerminimierung verstehen und auch wahrscheinliche Anwendungsbereiche auf kurze Sicht verstehen. Du wirst außerdem in der Lage sein,
all diese Algorithmen in Qiskit umzusetzen, und schließlich erwarten wir, dass du Rauschen und den Umgang damit verstehen kannst.
Fangen wir also an. Quantum Computing ist eine aufregende neue Technologie in einem frühen Entwicklungsstadium, aber es ist nur
ein Kapitel in der Geschichte der Berechnung, die Tausende von Jahren zurückreicht. Ich denke, es ist wichtig, diesen
Kontext zu verstehen, denn er macht das, was wir hier anstreben, etwas intuitiver, vorhersehbarer und weniger
Science-Fiction. Seit der Antike mussten wir als Menschen Berechnungen durchführen oder
mit anderen Worten Informationen nach bestimmten Regeln und Einschränkungen verarbeiten, um
Kommunikation, Bauwesen, Handel, Wissenschaft und alle anderen Lebensbereiche zu ermöglichen. Wir haben die physische Welt um
Hilfe gebeten und durch geniale Entdeckungen Geräte konstruiert, die uns beim Rechnen helfen. Früher wurden Geräte aus
Holz, Knochen und Knotenschnüren hergestellt, und sie speicherten Informationen und erleichterten Berechnungen ganz anders als wir es heute tun.
Mechanische Geräte aus Hebeln, Zahnrädern und anderen Maschinen entwickelten sich von frühen astronomischen Uhren über
Taschenrechner bis hin zu ausgefeilten Rechengeräten wie Differentialanalysatoren, die Gleichungen mithilfe von Rädern und
rotierenden Scheiben lösten. Sogar die Schreibtechnologie hat in dieser Geschichte eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, da sie es Menschen ermöglichte,
Berechnungen durchzuführen, zu denen sie sonst nicht in der Lage gewesen wären. Wenn wir heute an Computer denken, denken wir meist an
elektronische Digitalcomputer – aber das ist eine vergleichsweise junge Technologie. Elektronische Digitalcomputer
wurden erstmals in den 1940er Jahren gebaut. Das älteste bekannte Werkzeug für Berechnungen ist eigentlich der sumerische Abakus,
von dem Experten annehmen, dass er in Babylon um 2700 bis 2300 v. Chr. erfunden wurde. Das ist wirklich
sehr lange her. Aber wir haben immer mehr über die natürliche Welt erfahren – von Archimedes über Euklid bis hin zu
Einstein. Unser Bedarf an mehr Rechenressourcen ist explodiert. Heute haben wir Supercomputer, die im Wesentlichen
viele sehr leistungsstarke Computer sind, die parallel zusammengeschaltet sind. Sie sind eines der besten Werkzeuge, die die Menschheit hat, um
schwierige Probleme zu lösen. Aber es gibt noch viele Probleme, die selbst diese mächtigen Computer niemals
lösen werden können – mehr dazu später. Wir haben also festgestellt, dass Menschen Physik und Natur nutzen, um uns zu helfen,
seit Tausenden von Jahren zu rechnen, und um uns bei unserem nie endenden Streben nach mehr und größeren Berechnungen zu unterstützen. Du bist vielleicht schon
mit dem Mooreschen Gesetz vertraut. Es ist eigentlich kein Gesetz im eigentlichen Sinne, sondern eine Beobachtung – der Teil mit dem „Gesetz" ist meiner Meinung nach etwas
augenzwinkernd gemeint. Die maximale Anzahl von Transistoren in einem integrierten Schaltkreis – also im Wesentlichen einem Computerchip –
sich etwa alle 2 Jahre verdoppelt – über die letzten 5 Jahrzehnte haben wir das nicht nur beobachtet, sondern auch großen Nutzen daraus gezogen
mit mehr Transistoren können wir mehr und schnellere Berechnungen durchführen – das ist im Wesentlichen dafür verantwortlich,
dass Computer im Laufe der Zeit immer leistungsfähiger und kleiner werden. Es gibt jedoch schlechte Nachrichten: Moore's Law stirbt
Experten sind sich uneinig, wann Moore's Law sein endgültiges Ende finden wird, aber einige sagen, es hat bereits stattgefunden – auch wenn wir vielleicht nicht
genau wissen, wann wir unsere Grenze erreichen werden, wissen wir, dass es irgendwann unvermeidlich ist, weil einige Transistorteile
physisch nicht kleiner gemacht werden können – du kannst zum Beispiel keinen Transistor bauen, der kleiner als ein Atom ist – das
ist natürlich völlig unphysikalisch, klingt albern, aber das sind die Grenzen, mit denen wir tatsächlich arbeiten – also was
werden wir tun? Einfach aufgeben und sagen: Hey, das ist so gut wie es geht? Nein, das haben Menschen nie getan – zum Glück hat die Quantenmechanik
die Diskussion betreten. Die Quantenmechanik wurde in den 1920er Jahren entdeckt, und seitdem ist die Welt
buchstäblich nie mehr dieselbe gewesen – und wir könnten stundenlang über die revolutionären Entdeckungen sprechen, die
gemacht wurden, aber das ist nicht wirklich der Fokus dieses Kurses – stattdessen möchte ich klarstellen, dass wir wissen, dass
Quantenmechanik und Informatik bereits miteinander kompatibel sind. Die Erkenntnisse und das Verständnis der Natur,
die wir aus der Quantenmechanik gewonnen haben, haben unsere modernen Computer teilweise erst ermöglicht – ohne Quantenmechanik
würden wir zum Beispiel die Solid-State-Festplatte weder verstehen noch wahrscheinlich hätten wir sie erfinden können
Quantencomputing ist schlicht der nächste natürliche Schritt in dieser Evolution
aber Berechnung existiert nicht einfach im Vakuum – Information braucht ein Medium
Computing-Information nutzt die physische Welt und beeinflusst sie auch – das setzt Grenzen dafür, was überhaupt
physisch möglich ist, aber die Natur und die physischen Grenzen zu verstehen ist eigentlich das Ziel der Physik als
Disziplin – in gewisser Weise waren Physik und Informatik also schon immer miteinander verflochten. Ralph Landauer, ein Informatiker und
IBM-Forscher, erkannte vor Jahrzehnten, dass Information physisch ist – anders ausgedrückt: Information ist keine
abstrakte Einheit, sondern existiert nur durch physische Repräsentation. Landauers Prinzip stellt eine Verbindung
zwischen Information und den Gesetzen der Thermodynamik her – es gibt jedoch tatsächlich viele Verbindungen zwischen Physik und
Informatik. Die klassische Physik war alles, was wir bis vor Kurzem erkunden konnten, aber mit der Entdeckung der Quantenmechanik
stehen wir nun an der Schwelle, eine völlig neue Art zu rechnen zu erschaffen – und das ist großartig, denn
klassische Computer können nur annähern, was in der Natur tatsächlich passiert, und in einigen Fällen ist diese Annäherung sehr
begrenzt – das liegt daran, dass es wirklich, wirklich schwer ist, Maschinen, die den Gesetzen der klassischen Physik folgen, dazu zu bringen,
die Gesetze der Quantenphysik zu approximieren – und die Natur ist nicht klassisch, sie ist quantenmechanisch. Eine Analogie, die dir helfen könnte
zu verstehen, ist ein Windkanal – Strömungsdynamik ist bekanntermaßen schwer zu simulieren und mathematisch vorherzusagen
sogar etwas so Alltägliches wie ein Auto, das durch den Wind fährt – Automobilhersteller stellten fest, dass es tatsächlich
zu kostspielig und unpraktisch war, diese physische Interaktion zu simulieren, als sie Autos entwarfen – stattdessen
endeten sie damit, einen buchstäblichen Tunnel zu bauen, durch den Wind geblasen wird, und fuhren ein Auto einfach in den Tunnel
und schauten, wie es sich verhält – das ist analog zu dem, was ich meine, wenn ich sage, dass klassische Computer die Natur nur schlecht
annähern, und manchmal ist es zu kostspielig, sie das überhaupt versuchen zu lassen – anstatt den Wind zu simulieren,
erschaffen Forscher ihn einfach neu – ähnlich müssen Quantencomputer die Naturgesetze auf
molekularer Ebene nicht approximieren, weil sie diesen Gesetzen von Natur aus folgen – sie müssen nichts simulieren, sie emulieren es – und
dieselben Schwierigkeiten entstehen, wenn wir Batterien oder chemische Reaktionen simulieren – was uns zu unserem nächsten
Abschnitt führt: Quantencomputing – wofür ist es gut? Also
warum würden wir überhaupt daran denken, Quantenmechanik und Informatik zu kombinieren? Nun, es gibt bereits genug
Probleme, die zu schwierig, zu rechenintensiv für selbst unsere modernsten Supercomputer sind, um sie zu lösen
vielleicht sind das Probleme, auf die nur Forscher sehr fokussiert sind, aber ihre Auswirkungen könnten alle Teile der
Welt berühren – diese Probleme, an denen klassische Computer feststecken, sind Dinge, auf die wir als Gesellschaft immer mehr
auf Technologie angewiesen sind und die uns wirklich wichtig sind – wie Batterieeffizienz, Finanzmodellierung und
Optimierung und sogar, wie man bessere Flugzeuge baut – also warum auf Quantencomputer zurückgreifen? Nun, wir haben sehr gute Gründe
zu glauben, dass hier viel Potenzial steckt, und wir können Türen zu neuen Berechnungen öffnen, die derzeit selbst für
die leistungsfähigsten Supercomputer unerreichbar sind – in der Theorie bieten einige Quanten-Algorithmen Vorteile gegenüber den
bestmöglichen klassischen Algorithmen für manche Anwendungen – für andere Anwendungen gibt es zunehmende Hinweise, dass selbst
mit etwas Rauschen und Unvollkommenheiten Quantencomputer immer noch als Werkzeug eingesetzt werden können, um mit klassischen Brute-
Force-Lösungen zu konkurrieren – im Grunde ist es ein brandneues Werkzeug, und wir wollen noch mehr coole Dinge herausfinden, die wir damit tun können, aber wir können
auch auf Feynmans ursprüngliche Idee dafür zurückblicken, nämlich sie zu nutzen, um Physik und die Natur an sich zu verstehen
schließlich habe ich dir bereits gesagt, dass die Natur quantenmechanisch ist, nicht klassisch – und dieses Feld ist unglaublich reich, faszinierend und
interdisziplinär – es verbindet Physik, Informatik, Informationsverarbeitung und natürlich die spezifischen Bereiche der Anwendungsgebiete, an denen wir
interessiert sein könnten – im Gegensatz zu klassischen Computern hat jedoch nicht jeder einen Quantencomputer in der
Hosentasche – bis vor Kurzem musste man, wenn man mit einem Quantencomputer experimentieren wollte, sich einen bauen und pflegen,
meistens in einem tristen Keller-Labor einer Universität oder Forschungseinrichtung – und glaub mir, ich würde es wissen – das ist nicht mehr
der Fall. Im Jahr 2016 stellte IBM den ersten Quantenprozessor in die Cloud – er hatte damals nur fünf qubits und
ziemlich hohe Fehlerquoten, aber das war erst vor 8 Jahren – und schau, wie weit wir gekommen sind – also wo stehen wir heute?
Es gibt viele Parallelen zu den ganz frühen Tagen des modernen Computers – wie ich erwähnte, ist das eine sehr
schwierige Herausforderung, und erst in den letzten 8 Jahren wurden Quantencomputer für alle verfügbar, abgesehen von
denen, die in einem hochmodernen Labor oder einer Forschungseinrichtung arbeiten – aber in diesen vergangenen acht Jahren haben wir auf jedem
Gebiet Fortschritte gemacht: Prozessoren sind um Größenordnungen größer in der qubit-Anzahl, gates sind stark verbessert, und wir haben Methoden eingeführt,
um Fehler zu reduzieren oder zu mindern, die den Quantensystemen innewohnen, auch während wir voranschreiten, um fehlertolerante
Quantencomputer zu schaffen – jetzt können du und alle anderen einen dieser zahlreichen IBM-Quantenprozessoren nutzen, die
in der Cloud gehostet werden – fast alle davon sind die neuesten und leistungsstärksten Systeme mit über 100
qubits – aber es ist nicht nur die Größe der Prozessoren, die wichtig ist – das ist nur eine Kennzahl, um die wir uns kümmern, und
das macht Sinn, oder? Wenn wir mehr qubits haben, ist das offensichtlich besser, vorausgesetzt, dass die Erhöhung der Anzahl der qubits
die Leistung nicht beeinträchtigt. Das ist jedoch nicht immer der Fall – wir brauchen mehr hochwertige qubits, die sich nicht gegenseitig stören,
durch Übersprechen, wenn wir das nicht wollen. Wie die qubits miteinander verbunden sind, ist ebenfalls etwas Wichtiges, das man im Hinterkopf behalten sollte. Bei
supraleitenden circuits ist es eine Herausforderung herauszufinden, wie man die qubits am besten physisch verbindet. Eine weitere äußerst wichtige Kennzahl
ist die Zwei-qubit-gate-Treue. Gates, die auf einzelnen qubits laufen, sind nicht so fehleranfällig – Zwei-qubit-gates sind der weitaus
größere Problembereich und in der Regel eine der Hauptkennzahlen, anhand derer wir sehen, wie sich die Leistung über
die Zeit verbessert. Zwei-qubit-gates korrekt hinzubekommen ist entscheidend, da sie dafür verantwortlich sind, Verschränkung zwischen den qubits zu erzeugen,
was eines der physikalischen Phänomene ist, das Quantencomputern ihre Leistungsfähigkeit verleiht. Schließlich achten wir auf Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz –
wir müssen sicherstellen, dass die Zeit, die für das Ausführen eines Programms auf dem Quantenchip benötigt wird, so schnell und effizient wie möglich
abläuft. Wir bezeichnen diese drei Kennzahlen zusammen als Skalierung, Qualität und
Geschwindigkeit. Sie alle sind entscheidend für die Leistungsverbesserung. Jetzt möchte ich dir einige schnelle Diagramme zeigen, um das zu belegen, was ich
über die rasante Entwicklung der Technologie gesagt habe. Die Anzahl der qubits selbst ist am einfachsten zu
verstehen, denke ich, und IBM hat eine Roadmap veröffentlicht, wo wir in den nächsten Jahren in Bezug auf qubit-Anzahl
und Prozessorgröße stehen wollen. Für 2024, als wir dieses Video gedreht haben, liegen wir mit unserem Prozessor Heron und Condor genau im Plan.
Zur Qualität: Dieses Diagramm zeigt die mittlere Fehlerrate der Verschränkungs-gates für IBM Quantum-Prozessoren über die Zeit. Bedenke,
dass dies eine logarithmische Skala ist – der Fortschritt sieht also annähernd linear aus, ist aber tatsächlich viel schneller als das.
Schließlich haben wir die Geschwindigkeit. Dieses Diagramm zeigt den Fortschritt einer Kennzahl, die wir CLOPS nennen, was für circuit layer
operations per second steht. Entscheidend ist, dass CLOPS sowohl die Zeit, die für das Ausführen von circuits benötigt wird, als auch den erforderlichen Echtzeit- und
Beinahe-Echtzeit-klassischen Rechenaufwand erfasst. Im Wesentlichen ist CLOPS ein Maß dafür, wie schnell unsere Prozessoren bestimmte circuits in
Reihe ausführen können – als Maß für die ganzheitliche Systemgeschwindigkeit, das Quanten- und klassisches
Computing einschließt. Derzeit ist IBM zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme der einzige Quanten-Cloud-Anbieter, der Zugang zu 100-
plus-qubit-Maschinen bietet. Wie ich einige Folien zuvor erwähnt habe, ist bei 100 qubits oder ungefähr dort die klassische Simulation
vollständig zum Scheitern verurteilt. Groß angelegte Jobs, die auf diesen Maschinen ausgeführt werden, haben daher oft kein klassisches Äquivalent – das ist
einfach nicht möglich. Es gibt einige Nuancen und Tricks, mit denen man einige Teile eines circuit simulieren und dann andere
Teile separat bearbeiten kann. Aber im Allgemeinen wissen wir, dass ungefähr bei dieser Zahl Quantencomputer beginnen können, Dinge zu tun, die klassische Computer einfach nicht können.
IBM entschied daher, dass der Zugang zu diesen größeren Geräten für die breitere Community äußerst wichtig ist, denn alles,
was auf kleineren Geräten gemacht wird, ist klassisch simulierbar und kann daher keinen Quantum Advantage bringen. Die 100-qubit-
Geräte, die wir jetzt haben, sind noch fehlerhaft und noch verrauscht. Wir müssen also klug vorgehen, wie wir Jobs und
circuits auf ihnen ausführen. Einfach unseren circuit hinzuschreiben und Shift+Enter zu drücken, wird wahrscheinlich nicht zu irgendwas
Spektakulärem führen. Aber auch hier gibt es Tipps und Tricks, die wir anwenden können, sowie Best Practices, denen wir folgen können, um sogar noch
mehr Leistung aus diesen Geräten herauszuholen, was hoffentlich schneller zu Quantum Advantage führen wird, auch während wir weiterhin
an unseren fehlertoleranten Maschinen arbeiten und sie aufbauen. Dieses Diagramm zeigt die Simulationskosten,
also die Zeit, die benötigt wird, um ein Problem auf klassischen Computern und Quantencomputern mit Fehler-
minderung und Fehlerkorrektur zu lösen. Die klassische Berechnungslinie skaliert also exponentiell mit wachsender circuit-Komplexität.
Bei einfachen circuits hier unten spielt das keine Rolle, aber es ist offensichtlich problematisch, wenn die Komplexität zunimmt, denn das
macht die Simulationskosten sehr schnell sehr teuer. Fehlerminderung skaliert besser – wenn also die Komplexität des
circuit zunimmt, ist das der Bereich, in dem wir sein wollen. Wir befinden uns derzeit hier, wo klassische Methoden und Quantenmethoden sich für
einige Anwendungen in etwa die Waage halten, und Fehlerkorrektur könnte am vorzuziehendsten sein und skaliert sehr
gut – wir sind nur noch nicht dort. In der Zwischenzeit werden wir uns weiterhin auf Fehlerminderung konzentrieren und möglichst schnell in diesen
Bereich des Quantum Utility zu gelangen, und indem wir verschiedene Fehlerminderungsverfahren nutzen, die wir
in dieser Serie kennenlernen werden, wollen wir Anwendungsbereiche finden, die sehr bald von Quantum Utility profitieren können. Und das ist
wirklich das Herzstück dieses Kurses: Wir haben diese Maschinen, wir glauben, sie sind in der Lage, einige wirklich interessante
Forschung zu ermöglichen – wie nutzen wir sie also? In diesem letzten Abschnitt der Episode wollen wir kurz Anwendungsbereiche für
praktisches Quantencomputing besprechen. Es gibt drei Hauptbereiche, die wir am aufregendsten finden und bei denen wir Wege für Quantum
Utility erkunden wollen. Der erste ist die Simulation der Natur. Das hat mit der Simulation molekularer oder atomarer Wechselwirkungen zu tun, und das ist
wirklich wichtig für Bereiche der Materialwissenschaft und Chemie. Aus den Gründen, die wir zuvor besprochen haben, denken wir, dass Quanten-
computer dabei deutlich besser sein werden als ihre klassischen Pendants. Als nächstes kommt Suche und
Optimierung. Der wichtigste Algorithmus hier heißt QAOA – ein hybrides klassisch-quantenmäßiges Verfahren. QAOA verwendet einen
klassischen Computer, um optimale Parameter für einen Quanten-circuit zu trainieren und zu finden, und wird das hoffentlich
viel effizienter tun können als jeder der Computer allein. Schließlich haben wir Mathematik und die Verarbeitung strukturierter Daten. Quanten-
computer sind wirklich gut darin, Struktur in unübersichtlichen Daten zu finden, wo du, ich oder ein typischer Computer vielleicht nichts
sehen würden. Quantum Machine Learning ist in diesem Bereich vielversprechend, und wir wollen das für Aufgaben wie Feature-
Extraktion und Mustererkennung nutzen. Es ist wirklich eine sehr aufregende Zeit für uns, die wir im
Bereich des Quantencomputings arbeiten. Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte können wir beginnen, einen Bereich des Computings zu erkunden, der jenseits des
klassischen Computings liegt. Einige von euch, die das hier schauen, spielen möglicherweise eine ähnliche Rolle wie die frühen Pioniere des
Computings, die keine Vorstellung davon hatten, was folgen würde. T. J. Watson von IBM sagte sogar berühmt, er dachte, es gäbe
vielleicht einen Markt für nur zwei oder drei Computer überhaupt – und wie sehr lag er falsch!
Wir sind alle diese frühen Pioniere des Computings, aber in diesem neuen Bereich des Quantencomputings. Und Quanten-Computing wird oft
dem klassischen Computing als etwas deutlich Anderes und oft als Konkurrenz dazu gegenübergestellt. Aber mein
Ziel für diese Einführungsvorlesung war es, dich hoffentlich davon zu überzeugen, dass wir aus der Vogelperspektive das Quanten-
Computing einfach als das nächste Kapitel in einer langen Geschichte des Computings sehen können. Es liegt in unserer menschlichen Natur, neue Wege zu suchen,
zu berechnen und die Kraft der natürlichen Welt zu nutzen und herauszufinden, was wir damit anfangen können – und das tun wir seit
Jahrhunderten. Quantencomputing bietet uns ein neues Werkzeug in diesem Streben, und es liegt an uns zu entdecken, wie wir
die Leistung nutzen können, die es uns bietet. In der nächsten Lektion der Serie werden wir ein bisschen mehr über 100-qubit-Systeme sprechen
und einen Überblick über Qiskit, unser Quanten-Software-SDK, geben sowie darüber, wie man derzeit am besten mit diesen Maschinen interagiert. Danke fürs
Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal!